[Music]
now I live in paradise here don't tell
too many people want it show me
somewhere better
it's not possible nothing I kitesurf
which I like and I've been doing kite
surfing over the last seven or eight
years before that I and I still do
wind surf for the last 40 years and it's
lovely you've sets set a course and it's
like I just like flying on a cloud
if heavens like this I'd be very happy
to go
you out there you eat this oblivious to
the problems in life and he goes far as
I was little disposition it's just
beautiful it is a different world and
any problems any hiccups
they just by passion this is lovely you
know it's poetry of motion when you're
open and when I die and I'm getting near
the end of my life I'm hoping that this
kite up there
sadly my wife died 16 and a half years
ago and very quick all in two days
breast cancer and she had one chemo and
on the Saturday lunchtime we gotta go
out and she wasn't very well and she
within two days she died and when I saw
that I thought I'll change my life and I
started living life all the time I spent
the first three four years away nine
months a year I was windsurfing kiting
skiing snowboarding when all on the
world doing these things and then after
about three or four years the pain is
going so you come back and join what one
would term a natural life after I see
him how my wife left us this world I
changed my way of thinking it could be
tomorrow be gone so I live each day to
the phone
you'll never know when you gotta go
although I think I'm healthy I can be
dead tomorrow hence why I do all the
things I do
I was in there in Italian lakes about
three four years ago and there's no room
and I saw to my belief a man on a
windsurfer sculling side there's no wind
so we can still get out and do something
and hopefully this is the first time
I've tried it and it may work I'm
looking forward to it because today it
there's no wind and it's ideal for what
I want you to do having got the water
where I love and where I go being my age
and the bottom of people think I just do
what I want to do and I know very well
if they had the guts or the ingenuity
they would also like to be with me but
sadly a lot of people don't do what I do
God knows why but there you are I was
under water a few months ago and I
didn't want to stop at all then I
thought I just love you and I thought
then I'm gonna live another 10 years but
I tell my friends they don't like that
you think contigo before then take this
last I suppose 10 15 years I've slowed
down I don't run like it used to
I can't jump about I haven't changed my
ideas I'm principal in how I think about
life blend a few lessons over the way
but I'm still basic the same person I'm
an old man but with young thoughts and
I've never changed and the day does
change I will die
[Music]